[Music]
john wick is now in effect
[Music]
not much is already known about john
wick chapter 4 so far the only thing
that is clear is that the sequel will
probably follow on directly from the end
of part 3 and that will be released next
year it is very likely that jon will
take care of winston the high table in
his own style together with the bowery
king and the new sequel of the franchise
it's not yet clear whether old
companions like sophia will work with
him again but there's hardly anything
anyway that could stop jon from his
quest for revenge first let's talk about
the previously mentioned bowery king
after he was almost killed by assassin
zero in part three balry king who was
severely injured by the attack swears
revenge and saves the equally wounded
john wick the impression is given that
in part 4 the two of them will fight
side by side against the high table in
an attempt to bring it down the bowery
king can call on a whole army of killers
and their homeless luck and together
with the already more than
battle-hardened baba yaga they certainly
can't be considered a bad adversary what
makes the whole thing even more exciting
is that the respective actors behind the
film characters already have more than
enough shared experience in front of the
camera after all ken reeves and lawrence
fishburne already know each other from
the matrix trilogy there is also
speculation that the high table will
take on greater importance so far in
every john wick film there have more or
less been concrete hints about the
mysterious interior life of the high
table the last part focused roughly on
the different methods of punishment and
the way the educator works the former
was impressively illustrated when john
wick had to cut off a finger in front of
the elder's eyes due to the thrilling
subject matter and the secretiveness we
definitely speculate on deeper insights
into the functioning of the high table
and hope that we will also get to see a
few new officials with the
correspondingly new cast the third and
last thing we predict is that the
ballerinas who were discussed in more
detail at the beginning of john wick 3
will be brought more into focus the
organization with its ruthless leader
definitely offers more than enough
material for some action-packed
appearances in part 4. particularly due
to the fact that john wick has a serious
past with a ballerinas we believe that
more attention will be paid to them in
the future what makes us even more
optimistic is that a spin-off about the
ballerinas is in the planning stage so
we'll be hearing more about the
professional killer squad in the future
anyhow therefore it would almost be a
good idea to do a little advertising for
the spin-off in john wick 4.
[Music]
you